good morning everyone how are we feeling
this morning
[Applause]
we've been learning today
we're here to talk to you about how to
improve machine learning from Human
feedback
now before we begin a little bit about
us we're part of the team behind label
Studio
it's a open source tool for data
labeling created by hartex I'm Erin I'm
the senior developer Community Advocate
and this is Nikolai he's the CTO and one
of the co-founders behind label Studio
we're really excited today to be here to
explore reinforcement learning from
Human feedback and other ways to improve
your large language models or other
large foundational models but
if you've never wrote in a Model A day
in your life or you've never even typed
a single line of python
do not be scared
this talk does dive into it from a
theoretical perspective but for those of
you wanting to get your hands dirty
we'll be providing a notebook for you
and a live demonstration of how this is
possible all within 30 minutes think
we're up to it
yeah I see some excitement here all
right without further Ado let's begin
nothing if you don't have a minor
technical error
all right as many of you may have known
or noticed large foundational models
have hit the cultural Zeitgeist we've
all heard it we were all participating
in climbing to get into that room
talking about chat GPT yesterday
and we've all played around with dolly
or Bert or many of the other large
foundational models that exist
however they come at a cost we've all
probably heard it especially if you work
at the world of machine learning my
parents ask me every day are you
building the next Terminator
Mom I'm not you're welcome
I know major lame
AI isn't taking over the world this talk
is actually the opposite of that
we're going to be talking today about
making the technology that powers much
of our machine learning world just a
little bit more human
because we believe that these large
generative models are better with a
little human signal
so why does this matter
if you've been on the internet product
hunt or across the web you likely have
noticed a trend happening
slap a shiny front end on the top of
chat GPT AI like API bam that's a new
startup Innovation I think I've seen it
on product hunt more than plenty times
and I'm no shade there if that's what
you're into
but we need to recognize that these
large foundational models bigger isn't
always better
at its core because these models are
trained on such a wide data set and
create such a wide variety of content in
it
these internet trained models bring with
them internet scale biases
and for those of you who have been
online
we've got some problems
these biases can include gender bias
racial bias sexual bias poor data
quality and even limited applications
that's not my cup of tea
if we're here to make these large
foundational models actually useful for
your day of work
we should harness the power of
reinforcement learning
and in order to harness the power of
reinforcement learning we need to know
we need to know exactly what it is
we've probably seen it or joked around
about it the hottest new programming
language out there is actually English
now
all jokes aside there is some truth to
that statement
we need to be better at communicators
and understanding the social problems
that go into these large generation
models
reinforcement learning with human
feedback helps to adjust for the
problems that tend to come with
large-scale foundational models
through understanding the social things
that go into it and harnessing the power
of human feedback
so what exactly does that mean
at its core reinforcement learning is a
goal-oriented model to help ident but
seeks to identify similar actions or a
sequence of actions that maximizes
future of Rewards
these are able to success the best
output among a series of outputs
so where you're targeting the best goal
for your situation you're able to Target
for specificity individual use case and
so on and so forth
in comparison to unsupervised learning
or prompt engineering as we've seen
which relates on an existing model and
rather adopts your prompts to the model
of known limitations
what we do know is reinforcement
learning changes the model itself
these known limitations that happen that
come with these existing models include
harmful speech over generalized data
out of date data
racial gender and religious biases and
on top of everything else require large
computational resources and let's be
honest I have not convinced my employer
to get me that really fancy new Macbook
yet so we need to come up with a better
solution
reinforcement learning continues to
focus on optimizing for the end goal by
adapting the model itself
this also provides us an advantage when
dealing with new or uncertain
information
reinforcement learning allows you to
adapt based on existing Trends all
depending on that early human signal
with rlhf one can align model output
directly with one's specific needs
all at a fraction of that original cost
so what exactly does that mean
this means that we can align with our
specific use case take for example
Bloomberg gbt
that's a specific use case on a specific
set of data
and don't fret this all can be done in a
pretty accessible way thanks to our open
source landscape
there are plenty of Open Source tools
out there and we've provided a list at
the end of this talk for you to get your
hands dirty as well as a complete
awesome list of all the resources that
we've found
we're already seeing this used in the
wild in one case we've seen Bloomberg
GPT we've also seen fine which has been
another way that we've been training it
and even this morning I found someone
who is training it to reinforce and
identify and speak like Shakespeare
pretty freaking cool
so practically how did this work
as we discussed our large language
models train off of almost everything on
the internet
Pikachu face memes Nyan Cat you get the
picture
now what the difference is when we start
working on our prompts we'll have the
first prompt say what is a dog and begin
ranking put it through our large
language model and then begin ranking
the outputs from this prompt in this
example our model generated the answer
pair a furry animal and a free animal
four legs and a tail
we then put this output through a human
feedback loop typically done through
data labeling in our case this is when
you would apply a label Studio to better
identify and label the data which is the
better prompt
in this case we want to gamify for
detail
so our second output a furry animal with
four legs and a tail is the more
accurate option at this point our human
annotators gave this a better score
we'll then combine the results from our
human feedback back with the original
large language model to create a reward
or a preference model
what this does is it makes sure that
we're still aligned and we're still in
touch with what our end goal is to be in
this case we're targeting detail and
specificity
there are some underlying things that
that model understood like how human
language Works how to structure a
sentence but we also want to make sure
that it's aligned with the end goal
in many ways this reward or preference
model is one of the key innovations that
is allowed for large-scale foundational
models to innovate at such a rapid pace
as this industry grows we can only
expect that this reward model will have
further Innovations
in fact anthropic AI has identified this
as part of their inner iterative online
rlhf paper as an area for further
research and discoveries to be made
pretty cool
on top of this we have what's called an
arametric or an update rule
in order to ensure that we just don't
start outputting and spitting out
whatever to gamify this model or to best
fit a reward metric the error metric
makes sure that it actually makes sense
and it is independently calculated based
off of your original large foundational
model
in the final stages of model development
as your model is continuing to move
through this Loop and improving the base
model itself
we'll run the data through a cop another
additional copy of that large language
model to make sure everything's aligned
and then leave with our new tuned
language model
that delivers better results based on
our original goal
at this point your model is ready for
production
you can remove your model from the
training process to start really
receiving better outputs and models all
from that initial stats and internal
training data
we all try again theoretically
we've got some nods I'm seeing some
thoughts
who's ready to play in real time
let's see it in action and I'll be
passing it to Nikolai hey
guys thanks for the really nice
presentation so I can quickly walk you
through the notebook that allows you to
do to put your hands dirty on all these
steps including the reward model
training and putting this reward model
training into the final production so we
there is a repo where we collect the
tools and best practices here and you
can find the notebook example repeater
notebook so we go here
uh the best way is to open this notebook
in Google collab so let's do this
when you open the Google collab
environments quickly recap of what we're
going to do here is we train the reward
model that would mimic our
labelers preferences so that's by
showing them two examples here uh
they're gonna opt for one example and
collecting this human signal we train
our reward function the reward function
will replace the real humans and then we
plug this reward function into our
reinforcement learning training
procedure so maybe you're asking why not
just directing humans to the
reinforcement learning so training work
function is just cost you a few bucks
rather than getting the human labelers
consequently labeling signals it's too
costly and reward function will not
complain about working schedules and so
on so it's kind of like
good practice to incorporate all the
human signal into the actual
reinforcement Loop so
here we're going to install the all the
necessary libraries uh one of the very
good framework to uh to start iterating
and experimenting with the
reinforcement learning with the human
feedback is a trlx which gives you the
ability to inject this reward model once
it's trained
uh so the and plus you can start from
the uh Baseline models Collective the
hiking phase so in case we're gonna if
we for example training some analog of
charge GPD you can collect DPG or which
is simpler to example here gpd2 which is
smaller but you can actually get any
type of the model uh to
bootstrap your initial training pipeline
so once it's get done then we create the
generation steps so generation step aims
at creating the pairs of the examples
that you're gonna provide to your human
labelers so there is initial prompts and
the initial prompts
um
fit into the
Baseline model and it gives you outs
the generated examples so let's try
generated hope that environment already
set up
nothing like a Live code demo during a
25 minute talk right yeah
a little excitement for that in the
morning
yeah there's just the Testo likeness
good so we start generating the real
examples so here we see there is initial
prompt and there are model outputs that
we're going to compare with the human
labelers
so uh instead of waiting that I gonna go
to the
to the the data we already collected so
these are the same you see there's just
Json payload there's initial prompts
plus two outputs so let's get this link
and the next step is we gonna label that
in uh
within our labeling pipeline so
just give me a quick second
you can find it
really hard to see that what's you're
good your localhost 8080.
great so here uh the label studio is a
tool where you can create the projects
uh for your labeling needs for example
we create a project then we go and
import our data
let's put that here
great we import the data we see all our
data collected previously on the screen
and the final thing is that label Studio
comes with all tools that enables you to
label the generative thing so we go here
we find
the template that's provide you with
comparing to models and here we go so we
start comparing you can invite your
friends and hang out together by
clicking on and collecting the
preference of
everything you need so once the data is
collected the final step is to get this
data back to our pipeline
um
and
in a pipeline
we prepare the data collator that allows
you to set the data the annotations into
pytorch model and then we start the
training once the training is done so
the training actually fits your initial
model to produce just one single score
then this score is going to be used to
populate reinforcement learning
framework powered by teralax so you can
inspect here the convergence this is
again again this is just the toy example
here but in a real world practice you
can get more
robust and more long Pipeline and the
way it's more you can also inspect the
convergence in weights and by the sets
if you have that collected
and once your checkpoint is done once
your reward model is training
here's the the way how to get this model
into the reinforcement learning powered
by teralax Library it's going to take a
while unless you have very big computing
power or you can use the accelerator
library from The Hiding phase that gives
you the ability to connect to your to
computational resources very quick and
here we go the final output is the model
that allows you to
um
by incorporating your feedback allows
you to chat with and get your particular
tasks and your preferences established
so here is like very quick walkthrough
end to end from the beginning from the
initial model Baseline
collecting your data till the final
Model results that allows you to train
your model
from scratch till the final end
so then I pass
back I bet you didn't think you'd be
training a model in 10 minutes in this
talk did you
that all being said if this was a little
too quick Don't Panic we will be sharing
all of this on this repo as well as a QR
code at the end of the slide so don't
panic we've got you and of course we're
always here if you've got any questions
but like many Systems Technology isn't
perfect so we would be remiss if we
didn't discuss some of the problems with
rlhf
it as with many things it's darn humans
we ruin everything
this lack of programmatic reward Rewards
Bad actors
you can't control Perfect People human
judgments of behavior are at the end of
the day a key role in reinforcement
learning
our lhf
relies on poor annotator training or
relies on social engineering and data
Integrity just as much as it does
technical skill
poor annotator training or onboarding
can lead to models that optimize for the
wrong things
making sure that your human annotators
are well informed on the goal that
you're trying to achieve looking at how
annotation scores rank among two
different annotators and keeping people
motivated and creating a positive
environment for your annotators can go a
long way in building a more positive and
improved model set and a better model
and a better more holistic Integrity in
the world of machine learning as a whole
if you really enjoyed this talk I'd love
to see you try it out for yourself if
you have any questions feel free reach
out to us online
reach out to us via email we'd love to
take it and we'll answer audience
questions now but thank you
[Applause]
thank you for that great presentation I
think my teacher there's just said I
mustn't do like slides like this
okay
I have read many of your questions on
slido
feel free to vote questions up you
really like
but we can start with the first one how
much human feedback is needed to get
good results
it's a good question yeah that's great
question and like it's the same as like
how much data they needed to build a
good model of course the answer is it
really depends and experiment try
depending on what type of the task you
are trying to solve and how complicated
this task is
so there are reports that for making the
instruct gpt-like models that you don't
need to huge amount of data especially
if your instructions are in narrow
domain but for broader tasks for
allowing like to mitigating some biases
harm or whatever you want to
get rid of from your model that may
involve more data to be labeled to
ensure that it is robust
a lot of that also comes into the
training of the annotators itself when
your annotators and you've done the work
to properly prepare your annotators by
having a diverse set of people looking
and reviewing the data set as well as
them being well informed you can
actually reduce the amount of time it
takes to train the model or the number
of human annotations needed however if
your annotators are all over the place
and can't come to agreement
again we've got a social engineering
problem on our hands not necessarily A
technological one
your next question is what are the
trade-offs of using a trained reward
function instead of more labeled data
how to quantify that
quantify it
yeah it's the
qualifiable is like the the hard part
yeah the hardest for a moment so when
you actually use the direct signal like
direct supervision signal you enforce
your model to follow specific targets
and these targets can be well defined or
not well defined and eventually if you
uh find your initial problem you'll
Define it you need to re-establish your
training Pipeline and training procedure
whereas with human feedback concept you
can continuously learn and continuously
incorporate human signals into the model
and re-establishing the guidelines for
human annotators but in a nutshell they
both work similarly the way they differ
is how you structure your
uh annotation pipeline through how you
structure your guidance and like
basically the framework how you're
capturing human knowledge into the
models
next question which 11 people liked how
is the reward model trained how many
liars are Frozen from the ground
so if you repeat the question who how is
the reward model trained how many layers
are Frozen from the original
are paired in tandem so we are always
building through the same loop at the
same time if you want to kind of
continue yeah the good question is like
how are we practicing uh like of course
it should not be used the entire
um backbone model to try and to to train
from scratch like most of the layers are
used for uh for doing extraction of the
feature and kind of allowing this model
to behave in a similar space as the
model you are going to train with reward
model so it's kind of like the head of
the model can be unfrozen then you
retrain it but with which is the most
important that your target should
consist of just the reward score that
you're gonna plug in and like as soon as
you see that the convergence is well
enough with the human laborers that's
that means a good sign that you can
start using utilizing this model in uh
Errol uh framework in RL pipeline
how to keep laborers motivated
this is where their whole quality of
life and ethics comes in is
understanding the core problem
I think we've seen this with um when we
Outsource labeling without clear
intentions and getting them
understanding why they're labeling in
the core process is something we witness
a lot
um
keeping people motivated with intentions
yeah and actually like incorporating the
feedback to the humans like not only the
feedback to machine from humans but
humans also love feedback so when more
feedback you put into the labeling
procedure like you can't do this for
sort of communication like more they see
the progress of what they are doing more
motivated they become you know positive
reinforcement doesn't only just work for
models
I like being told I'm doing a good job
too
is there a rule of thumb how much
samples and context of the overall data
the human have to rank until it is good
shape
yeah I think again this is one of those
really tricky contextual ones and I hate
to give the cop-out answer of it depends
but like many things in development and
machine learning it depends if your
models are well if your annotators are
well trained and they're well targeted
you can kind of speed up that process
but you're really looking for when the
annotations and that reward function
starts to align and you can start to see
that positive reinforcement there
next question do you think it makes
sense to also utilize weak supervision
for example snorkel AI combined with RL
instead of human feedback to improve the
models
yeah there is also like the early
experiments where like sentiments models
can be also used to drive up the rewards
for producing positive feedback but
again the the core idea here like humans
are very flexible in changing the goals
and uh any all you can always sit down
with a friends and say okay guys let's
do this stuff right now and let's follow
this particular rule which is not
available with the model so you always
need to get the model first trained and
annotators they can pick up very quickly
what's exactly their goal of the this
aligning is and yeah that means that
whatever you come up with the actual
goal you can quickly get this goal into
these targets into their model which is
good yeah in comparison when you're
actually retraining the model the cool
thing is is it's a more long-lasting and
a more iterative approach rather than
gamifying like your prompt to best fit
an existing model you do have you have
adjusted that core data
could it be could it be applied to
regress regression model for example
price prediction
yeah
you mean when you're at the regression
which means like it's not just the
categorical predictions yeah that's what
it pointed out yeah
is it useful to let multiple annotators
label the same question and hopefully
have agreeing judgments for more robust
human signal oh yeah yeah I was gonna
say the more you
more if you better um
how many people like pineapple and pizza
like that's always a controversial one I
think
I think we might if we're labeling and
building a model for the best pizza type
um we might have a serious debate on our
hands here and that's why having more
annotators and actually also being
explicit with what your prompts are is
really important so say we are building
a new pizza restaurant that we wanted to
get data labeling in for this is a very
extreme example but that only wanted
pineapple on pizza and we picked only
people who like pineapple and pizza we
might have a pretty screwed up data set
but by inviting a diverse set of models
or diverse set of annotators we help can
align to see what is the best actual
solution not just the best of a limited
subset
questioned by Elias could it apply to
imagine Generations if so would it be
better than dream both or similar
yeah I also didn't get clearly the
question clearly can we read it and it
sounds like a very interesting could it
apply to imagine Generations yeah to
image generation yeah yeah actually we
are aiming at since like uh the
multi-modality here is the key so right
now there are a lot of experiments with
the natural language processing and
steering models to the natural language
task but the same concept of steering
model towards the human signal towards
the human feedback for any modality for
the images applied here it's like you
can pick the whatever image you like or
you can pick the whatever the audio
generated or so it's absolutely open for
any data domains which means I think we
build I believe that very soon we're
gonna see a lot of models comes to the
plate Arrow shaft by humans from
different domains
okay thank you for your great
presentation and for answering all these
questions
thank you thank you for all being here
[Applause]